[Musique]
choisir du thon en conserve parmi toute
l'offre disponible
c'est du sport identifions d'abord les
deux gros joint ce qu'on appelle ton
blanc et le temps germes en aidant les
concerts de tons pâles deux espèces de
thons sont présentes listao et à
nageoires gens
[Musique]
m'attendais pas à ça mais le ton par un
goût beaucoup plus prononcée beaucoup
plus un goût de poisson beaucoup plus
prendre votre poisson oui oui c'est ça
mais les tombes là est beaucoup plus
subtile autre différence le prix le thon
blanc est généralement plus cher que le
ton pas mais qu'il soit blanc ou pal le
thon émietté ou en morceaux et moins
cher car il est fait à partir des
retailles de thon entier c'est de
thaïlande que proviennent presque toutes
les boîtes de temps et les poissons mis
en conserve dans cette région du monde
n'échappe pas à la pollution liée aux
mais recule
marc hamy aux spécialistes en
écotoxicologie étudie ses effets sur
l'humain le foetus peut développer des
problèmes neuro toxicologiques avec une
baisse de quotient intellectuel un
retard moteur un retard verbales mais ça
s'apprend dès bonne concentration quand
même c'est pas un phénomène qu'on
retrouve couramment la compagnie
cloverleaf vend chaque année près de 70
millions de conserves de thon au canada
guy boucher en est le responsable des
ventes
la seule restriction qu'on a de santé
canada c'est sur le thon blanc et la
raison c'est que c'est un plus gros
prédateur donc lui va consommer une
grande quantité de proies de sardines de
plus petits poissons qui contiennent du
mercure
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont eu tout le
mercure plus élevé mais qui quand même
bien en dessous des normes canadiennes
c'est une directive qui est fait pour
protéger les foetus et les jeunes
enfants qui sont en développement quand
ils sont en développement on veut
vraiment éviter leur exposition parce
que c'est un moment clé dans l'ordre
un intellectuel tout le reste la
population l'apport à sokone omni paul
de tons pâles ni propose et ongles en
conserve le scientifique et son équipe
poursuivent leurs recherches sur le
sujet présentement on estime que tout
mercure comprend dans notre corps peut
voir un poisson va dans notre sens
éventuellement distribuer dans notre
corps nos recherches ont indiqué que
c'est peut-être pauvres est donc avec le
temps passe ici on se rend compte que
seulement une petite proportion se
retrouve dans un acteur mais on pourrait
ajuster nos guides de consommation en
attendant c'est davantage le sodium
présent dans certaines conserves qui
doit nous préoccuper
ça varie énormément en termes de sodium
on va avoir justement des conserves qui
il indique clairement sans ajout de sel
dans le code du rin cost ici dans une
portion d'un tiers de temps g à titre de
comparaison si nous allons sur leur riz
au mari à l'huile d'olive pour le
contenant au complet nous avons 6 120 mg
de sodium
si on mange la conserve au complet c'est
un 120 mg là on est on rentre dans le
groupe des charcuteries le pratiquement
des 40 conserve de thon étudie onze se
retrouve au par des punitions pour excès
de sodium
si on parle de protéines - est-ce que
c'est une source de protéines
intéressant et on est con ça oui le thon
en conserve une très bonne source de
protéines
encore une fois c'est pratique on n'a
pas besoin de le cuire le préparer on
met ça dans une salade ou dans ce qu'on
veut donc oui ce un côté protéines c'est
très intéressant parce que même s'il est
tout petit mais là ici on est un 16
grammes de protéines parce que dans un
repos hobbies autour de 15,8 ancien
salade on va peut-être ajouter autre
chose est ce qu'on va acheter des noës
qu'on va acheter du fromage donc il faut
en voir d'autres sources de protéines
aussi en hauteur dans notre pas donc
c'est déjà un bon départ même avec la
petite la petite concerne riche en
protéines
le thon en conserve faire toutefois des
points lorsqu'il est question d'oméga 3
mais au niveau des oméga-3 le thon en
conserve c'est parce que de plus
intéressant si on compare avec d'autres
poissons gras par exemple saumon sauvage
va avoir deux fois plus de mega 3 que
dans la même portion de tombes là si le
temps est notre source d'omega-3 pratico
pratique qu'on va aller chercher un
petit peu à chaque semaine ça peut être
intéressant convient de considérer le
commun comme une source d'oméga 3
depuis quelques années de nouvelles
recrues ont fait leur apparition en
épicerie les consommateurs qui veulent
des produits des solutions rapides se
dirige vers les tons qu'on appelle à
valeur ajoutée donc des tons de bart où
on a ajouté des saveurs des aromates
il est en valeur ajoutée ça représente
présentement plus de 20 pour cent de
toutes les conserves de thon qui sont
vendus et 6,7 ce segment lequel en forte
croissance
alors ça avec différentes saveurs oui à
ces années quand on sait si ce n'était
pas déjà assez pratico-pratique la
conserve de thon on l'a assez zone et
pour vous quels sont les ingrédients de
ce temps sucre
troisième ingrédient pourquoi je
mettrais du fait que dans mon temps neuf
grammes
quand même c'est tout petit garçon une
conserve 2 cuillères à thé de siècle à
d'un test c'est du temps c'est pas comme
je lis pas de la confiture le truc est
de plus en plus de consommateurs
s'intéressent à la pêche durable
les fabricants ont compris et de
nombreux logo orne les conserves amis
des dauphins aujourd'hui c'était plus
tellement pertinent comme certification
tu pense qu'on devrait plutôt se fier à
des eaux chinoises et merci qu'on
reconnaît le plus à l'échelle mondiale
en fait c'est la certification du mtq et
le marine stewardship council
c'est l'organisation qui émet des
certifications sur les marques de
commerce travers le monde qu'ils
respectent des normes très strictes sur
justement les pêche durable le respect
de l'écosystème donc les marques on
retrouve les allemands qui ont la
certification msi où j'avais eu un écho
soit planète sélection et dans les
prochains mois des prochaines années
tous les produits corrosifs et je dirais
la majorité des marques dont 6
assujettis rouleau odienné si la
question de traçabilité commence aussi à
faire son apparition comme ici sur les
conserves irrésistible ou encore chez
clover leaf en fait depuis 2016 c'est
100% interactifs pour les consommateurs
avec le cas de la consoeur vous pouvez
apporter toutes les informations à
savoir l'espèce comment ils étaient
pêchées dans quel océan
par quel bateau même la durée de sorties
en mer du bateau et qu'elles ''s'en le
mien conserve
[Musique]
à vous maintenant de choisir vos étoiles
du mak pour leur implication face à la
pêche durable certainement se distingue
pour leur faiblesse en sodium beaucoup
en contiennent peu ou pas pour repris
tous les tons parle en morceaux ou
émietté
[Applaudissements]